[Musica]
buonasera agosto felice di essere a casa
chi di voi non ha mai giocato a monopoly
o al gioco dell'oca
alzi la mano probabilmente tutti e
perché vi parlo di questi due giochi
perché questi sono due grandi classici
hanno fatto la storia del gioco ma non
lo sono più
nel senso che hanno un limite
il gioco il giocatore in questi due
giochi non è protagonista lo subisce un
po io tiro un dado mi muovo faccio
quello che il dado mi dice io vi voglio
raccontare di un altro mondo un mondo
diverso
il mondo del gioco da tavolo moderno che
un mondo fatto di tantissime aziende e
di più di 5.000 giochi che escono ogni
anno e dietro questi 5.000 giochi c'è
qualcuno che li inventa e io sono uno di
questi inventò giochi da tavolo quando
lo dico la gente rimane anche un po così
allibita perché pensa che non possa
neanche esistere un lavoro del genere
e allora attorno un po indietro e vi
dico come ho fatto ad entrare in una
scatola il mio percorso nasce veramente
da bambino nel senso che io ho avuto una
mamma che mi ha fatto giocare tantissimo
a busto poi c'erano due negozi molto
belli dove io entravo e vi devo queste
scatole che chiedevo per natale e che
cosa succede quando a natale ricevi un
dono tool lo ha pero spacchetti e dentro
sé qualcosa che tu vedi subito se è un
orologio lo vedi subito invece se ricevi
un gioco c'è un'altra sorpresa perché la
scatola dentro a qualcosa che tu non
conosci e tu ci vuoi entrare è un po
come quando entri in un mondo magico in
un mondo diverso in un mondo irreale ma
che li che puoi toccare quindi apre
questa scatola come quando annusi e
quando aprì un libro è lo annusi prendi
le pedine cerchi di guardare il
tabellone come insomma cerchi di
ambientarti
nuovo mondo e cosa succede diventi la
pedina tu stesso sei un po lilliput
e sai gulliver la muovi massei la pedina
un mondo magico è un mondo fatto di
regole e le regole nei giochi si
rispettano non come nella vita spesso
noi passiamo col rosso non rispettiamo
non mettiamo la cintura mentre se voi
andate in un campetto e vedete i bambini
giocare loro si danno delle regole e
giocano con quelle regole lì e io sono
partito dalle regole o ho fatto una cosa
un po strana quella che in gergo noi
chiamiamo house rules cioè modificava i
giochi per vedere se erano più belli ho
iniziato da lì modificando regole di
giochi che c'erano già e ho iniziato a
fare i miei primi giochi o ti diamo
anche i miei amici però mi volevano bene
quindi forse giocavano con me ma poi la
vita ti cambia nel senso che ti porta su
altre strade e mi sono laureato in
ingegneria e poi ci torneremo con
l'ingegneria e quindi sono stato
all'estero sono stati in africa ho fatto
strade sono stati in austria ho fatto
gallerie ma dentro di me c'era il seme
del gioco io volevo fare dei giochi
volevo fare un gioco da tavolo e nel
ho creato il mio primo gioco un gioco
che voi dite va bene il 91 che poi è
stato pubblicato e uno dice vabbè quanto
ci avrei messo pubblicarlo beh sommesso
16 anni si è questo gioco
oggi pazzescamente è connesso con questo
evento perché questo gioco non lo
trovate in italia e solo in germania e
il titolo ever been dong jesus che vuol
dire cercando la connessione
e stata incredibile questa cosa quando
mi hanno detto di questa cosa e quindi
ho il piacere di raccontarvela è però
cosa so cosa è successo in questi sedici
anni perché sono lunghi e 16 anni
beh ho fatto tutti gli errori che si
potevano fare proprio tutti tutti
sbagliato cioè andato delle aziende
sbagliata è parlato con le persone
sbagliate
insomma un disastro
quando nel 1998 si erano ancora i fax mi
arriva in ufficio un fax e co scritto
premio archimede per autori inediti
l'ho detto è il mio cioè io c'ho gioco
pronto c'è il premio era a cagli
me lo ricordo perché non sapevo neanche
che esistesse cagli tra l'altro andateci
perché una città bellissima e sto per
uscire di casa per andare a cagli e
ricevo una telefonata e in questa
telefonata mi dicono avremmo piacere che
lei venisse a cagli perché il suo gioco
è tra i primi dieci giochi nominati io
ho fatto quella strada volando sono
arrivato a cagli il gioco è andato bene
ha avuto una nomination e finalmente
sono entrato in contatto con un mondo
con cui volevo entrare in contatto
poi da lì però la strada è stata lunga
fino a quando nel 2007 una grande casa
tedesca ha finalmente pubblicato il mio
gioco e sono entrato in questo mondo
dalla porta principale
mi si sono aperte tantissime altre porte
e tantissime altre connessioni in italia
esistono dei pazzi come me che si alzano
alla mattina e cercano di creare
qualcosa per fare divertire le persone e
ci siamo anche radunati una volta la
prima volta adesso ne sono passati tanti
di anni sopra uno stanzino di una
cooperativa piossasco un piccolo paese
e lì ho conosciuto altri autori come me
tra questi altri autori
ho conosciuto
un ragazzo fantastico
si chiama luca luca come me fa
l'architetto e ci siamo proprio
incontrati ci siamo connessi
siamo diventati per usare un termine
moderno una coppia ludica di fatto e
faccio e facciamo giochi insieme siamo
talmente connessi che a volte le idee
non si sa più se arrivano da lui
arrivano da me e quando il gioco finisce
non si sa più neanche chi l'ha creato ma
esce fluisce poi abbiamo avuto la
fortuna ho avuto la fortuna di essere al
momento giusto al posto giusto ed
incontrare una persona che ha detto io
ho bisogno di lei e abbiamo creato con
questa persona
la prima linea di giochi da tavolo
prescolare per bambini in italia
io e luca con grande orgoglio lo posso
dire
su questo palco e come creare un gioco
da tavolo come si fa a creare un gioco
da tavolo me lo chiedono in tanti e non
lo so ci vuole fantasia creatività a
guardare il mondo essere curiosi aprire
un libro o guardare un film da qualsiasi
situazione
potete trovare uno spunto per creare un
gioco da tavolo però forse a questo
punto la mia vita non era così completa
perché si è vero faccio il gioco dentro
le scatole e adesso ne ho fatti tanti e
li ho fatti veramente tanti e in questo
momento ancora di più abbiamo appena
firmato settimana scorsa un contratto
con un'azienda coreana
quindi i nostri giochi ormai sono nelle
case dei bambini di tutto il mondo
ho ricevuto i resoconti è il primo paese
in alto era l'angola
questo per dirvi quanto può essere
potente un gioco da tavolo e quanto può
far bene perché entra in contatto
con le persone con le famiglie ed è
proprio di questo che voglio parlarvi
del fatto di come entrare in sintonia
attraverso un gioco da tavolo con le
altre persone perché il gioco da tavolo
vedete è veramente un mondo magico ci si
siede e ci si relaziona ci si guarda
negli occhi si parla e non è importante
vincere o perdere ma è importante è
l'emozione che il gioco ti trasmette la
mossa che hai fatto avere preso in giro
l'altro
insomma questo è quello che io volevo
trasmettere ea un certo punto ho capito
che forse non mi bastava più stare
dentro nella scatola ma avrei dovuto
portare questa esperienza fuori dalla
scatola ed è nata una mia seconda vita
quella fuori dalla scatola sempre
attraverso il gioco e come io e una
pedagogista sarà evangelista un tesoro
abbiamo creato un piccolo format che si
chiama vieni a giocare con me punto
esclamativo punto di domanda è com'è
questo format non è rivolto ai bambini è
una frase che noi diciamo che un
genitore dovrebbe dire al suo figlio
cioè come un genitore dovrebbe
relazionarsi con un bambino attraverso
il gioco
cerchiamo di portare il gioco nelle
famiglie vedete il gioco da tavolo ha un
vantaggio
quando vedete su una scatola di solito
c'è scritto l'età fino a 99 anni vuol
dire che è adatto a tutti che grandi e
piccini ci possono giocare ed è un ponte
di relazione fantastico e a piana a
piana alla cultura diversa piana l'età
diversa si gioca tutti sullo stesso
piano
quindi cosa abbiamo iniziato a fare
abbiamo iniziato a fare serate tematiche
proprio con le famiglie
l'abbiamo fatto con gli educatori
l'abbiamo fatto anche nelle aziende
perché vedete gli adulti spesso si
dimenticano di essere stati bambini
e perdono il senso del gioco e invece
loro hanno imparato giocando perché
l'unico canale che hanno i bambini di
comunicazione è quello ludico e quindi
ho cercato di riportare fuori il gioco a
contatto con le persone dentro le
persone e poi è successa un'altra cosa
e qui ritorna l'ingegneria uno pensa che
di solito un ingegnere sia una persona
un po noiosa che di solito fa molti
calcoli che vive dentro il suo studio e
invece forse alcuni ingegneri sono un po
diversi
una volta al miur sono stato a
presentare un progetto e qualcuno dopo
il mio intervento ha detto oggi
l'ingegnere borsa demolito lo stereotipo
dell'ingegnere tipo e questa cosa mi ha
fatto sorridere anche piacere nello
stesso tempo perché perché sì ho potuto
con la mia laurea in ingegneria toccare
anche altri mondi toccare il mondo della
scuola
sono stato al politecnico di milano a
fare un corso a dei ragazzi di
architettura sul gioco scenografico come
un gioco può essere anche fuori dalla
scatola dentro la città sono stato a
brera ci tornerò sono stato al
politecnico di torino a fare a fare un
seminario su come il gioco può far
crescere le persone e poi è successa
un'altra cosa ancora più importante
secondo me è ancora con una valenza
ancora più bella
ho unito il mio lavoro da ingegnere con
il gioco cosa è successo ho potuto fare
la progettazione anzi la coprogettazione
perché abbiamo ci siamo fatti aiutare
dai ragazzi dagli studenti per fare
questa cosa di una scuola di un plesso
scolastico una scuola grigia con 2.500
metri quadri di pavimento in auto
bloccante l'abbiamo rivoluzionata
l'abbiamo cambiata avevamo abbiamo avuto
anche la famosa botta di cio nel senso
la fortuna c'era una collina e noi
pensavamo che quella collina fosse piena
di porcheria quindi da bonificare
in realtà sotto quella collina abbiamo
trovato un rifugio anti aereo della
seconda guerra mondiale perfettamente
intatto un luogo di paura se ci pensate
e l'abbiamo trasformato in un luogo di
gioia abbiamo fatto sì che i ragazzi
entrassero nella collina scendessero
entrassero scusate nel bunker
risalissero sulla collina e uno scivolo
li portava giu che poi finiva in mezzo a
un vialetto dove dei gechi li
riportavano di nuovo un altro gioco
ho disegnato giochi dove giochi non
c'erano e poi un'ultima cosa voglio
dirvi un comune illuminato mi ha
chiamato recentemente e mi ha detto noi
dobbiamo fare il nuovo piano regolatore
del territorio e abbiamo pensato di
inserire il piano giochi cioè come
dovrebbe essere una città dal punto di
vista ludico per i suoi cittadini
nei prossimi anni una sfida della sicuro
ho redatto il piano giochi insieme ad
altre persone e la giunta ha stanziato
un notevole budget per questo piano
giochi che è un piano giochi innovativo
speciale porta le persone al centro
al centro degli sbarchi è una delle
prime cose che faremo
e questa è una palestra cales tenica
tale stecco vuol dire bello e forza e
come l'ho chiamata l'ho chiamata 13 99
come proprio i riportano le scatole
perché può essere usata da ragazzi dai
13 anni fino al 99 anni è un'altra cosa
ho fatto
in questo
piano giochi che è un po anche un piano
che ha una sua filosofia spesso voi
pensate
ho guardate quando andate in un parco
trovate un cartello questo cartello ha
di solito che cosa c'è scritto di dietro
non posso entrare i cani non possono
entrare insomma divieti e sanzioni bene
ho detto di fare dei nuovi cartelli dove
vorrei che ci fosse scritto in questo
parco si può saltare in questo parco si
può correre in questo parco si possono
raccogliere le carte che gli altri
abbandonano
insomma vorrei che questo parco tornasse
essere il centro della vostra comunità e
chiudo con una frase che non è mia è una
frase di bernard shaw e dice che l'uomo
non smette di giocare perché il vecchia
vecchia
perché smette di giocare grazie
[Applauso]